timbercomedy.com for all the live dates
we've got a lot of shows
coming up
and we're very excited about them here
we're just going to run through them
right now and then we're going to put
this in the front of the show glasgow
dublin
london
jacksonville charlotte new orleans
dallas austin chicago houston cincinnati
baby
northfield ohio sydney australia
melbourne australia brisbane australia
adelaide australia perth australia and
then that is it
this tour's over we're wrapping it up
we would love to see you on the road
thank you ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the tim dillon show hillary clinton
has just uh contracted the disease
she created covid 19.
bill tested negative and is feeling fine
this is from hillary's twitter he's
quarantining until our household
is fully in the clear movie
recommendations
appreciated
from hillary clinton uh and then jen
saki tweeted her
finally watching inventing anna and
recommend and highly recommend lots of
water tea and juice
jen sake
uh press secretary for joe biden
recommending inventing anna
the show on netflix about a con artist
in new york city to hillary clinton
interesting but a con artist who got
caught
and was not able to
swindle her way to
chappaqua
i can say where they live i mean people
know where they live it's public
information
i don't need to be alive
hillary is uh dealing with kovid she's
uh older she's an older woman so it's
always tough
when somebody who's an older woman
contracts covid and
she's a good woman and a woman who well
my grandmother loved her so that counts
for something right no matter what this
woman's done in her life
my my grandmother uh really cared about
her and uh she was like
gung-ho hillary clinton
here with ben avery of course everything
okay with you you have a very odd you've
had a very weird tone it's made a lot of
people uncomfortable i'm so i'm so
thrown off i feel like i've i've been
doing uh well you have a very like it's
a bossy like you get very bossy to
everyone when you're it's like your
studio and you're like very like oh
yes you do you and everybody realizes it
you have a very
kind of bossy authoritarian i feel like
i'm intentionally very open
i open heart and i feel like i'm very
encouraging
and i feel like i bring a lot of uh i
feel like i light up a room a little bit
not like a huge bulb like a huge bright
bulb of light like a studio light but i
definitely i'm carrying like a candle or
like a torch or something i come in and
i just feel like hey ben's here
everything's okay okay
you know that is your word word quota
for the next three episodes
you're not to utter another word you you
are
so out of line
by the way i was with devin and ida
richie friends of ours it's late night
in the studio
just hanging out
and uh the other day we're on a plane
now by the way i sit in first class he
sits and coaches the way it is it's the
way it is it's called capitalism
uh and
i look back
he's sitting
in the row
right
behind the first class curtain
trolling me
essentially
sitting in like a comfort seat
or some type of like
higher
priced seat
and i'm looking at him i usually never
see him
and i walk sometimes to the back of the
plane
and i give him something that we get in
first class a hard-boiled egg or
something i
squirrel it away to him and he's sitting
right up there
but you know how god punishes him tell
everyone how what happened in the middle
of the flight tell everybody what
happened uh uh a younger white man is
sitting in the middle seat fit uh
started vomiting all the way wait a
minute how did you describe him a
younger white man and then you said fit
like he's fit he's fit okay what in
god's name
does that have to do with what happened
it's not who you would think would it
would be who would you think it would be
um
an older woman
of what race i don't know why jesus is
important well you specified race you
brought it up that's true that's kind of
weird i did that yeah
interesting what was a white guy
it was a white fit man the enemy
and what then happened to you he uh he
like like crazy started vomiting all
over his his groin in his crotch that's
right and it he did it so much he was
flailing around for uh that's right the
throw up bags and he couldn't there
weren't any and so he just kept going
like about five times went into my uh
ridge wallet backpack went on my shoes
one on my pants i'm stuck in the window
the guy in the aisle jumped up
immediately and i was just stuck there's
nothing i could do here's then what
happens they send them into first
i swear to god they send these dirty
pieces of [ __ ]
covered in vomit
into first class
to wash themselves off
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on
i i'm not vomiting
so you bring some schmuck from steerage
who's vomiting
into it's like a 2 000 ticket and this
monster who's vomiting
you know and i hope he's okay because he
said he passed out when the plane took
off yes these are bad sides he went
unconscious he said
we worry about him
and we want him to be okay but we don't
want him in first class covered in vomit
right
what is ron desantis doing in disney
world killing uh gay children
what's going on now
why is disney world disney world
is in like
have you heard about this uh you can't
say gay now don't say gay in florida if
you say gay
something happens something i don't know
what do they do they go they get you you
march or something
putin loves the don't say game though
putin's
we want to play devin's thing it was so
funny on the show oh yes yes
we're gonna play this this is a leaked
this is the reasons vladimir putin
invaded the ukraine
and
i was against the ukraine invasion in
principle
until i not keep going i'm almost there
well why prepare
you know what i mean it's three o'clock
in the morning we got the time
we got people breaking into the studio
persians are coming in here with kebabs
heidi's doing arabian nights
why prepare another three hours here
all right it's all right he's you know
he's been with the the dogs all day
okay so this is devin's uh video here
this is not devastating i didn't make
this this is leaked i just found it
audio
this is why
russia
has invaded uh the ukraine
the truth
[Music]
you got to watch it folks if you are
just listening to the show you got to
watch that as well and now of course
people actually this is when you learn
the uh intellect yeah of the american
public yeah it's truly terrifying people
thought it was real like 50 of people
legitimately still think it's real i'm
still getting messages like putin
doesn't give a [ __ ] about blm
[Music]
yeah
i doubt it one one of my favorite ones
is the guy goes
if this is putin we're in real trouble
it sounds like he's lost his mind
if this is putin we got a lot of
problems on our hands
because he seems unwell how did you do
russian that well it's i it sounds like
russian i guess i mean i say
at one point but i just looked up like
how to say hello and goodbye and it all
takes forever just to say one word in
russian and then you know you just add
issa rae let's do a ukraine war report
where is the ukraine right now
uh in terms of
the we have the russians who've advanced
they've done horrible things in maripole
they're targeting civilians
uh
you know
now they're saying it's it's the
stalemate the media keeps doing this by
the way is the media helping the ukraine
the media keeps going the russians are
losing the next day
a city gets burned to the ground
can the media stop running articles that
say like putin's hitting a stalemate
immediately after that happens they just
start shelling civilian centers
how about telling him he's winning
how about the media writing an article
saying it's over you've done a great job
like this isn't working this this idea
of just telling this guy he's losing
every fight like if i was in a ukraine i
go tell him it's good he's we they're
winning i know
tell him that he doesn't have to try so
hard
this isn't exactly the best strategy
here to keep telling the guy
he's uh and now we're pushing this coup
angle
we're saying that there's a coup
that and and mark galiotti who doesn't
return my messages anymore but he's a
really great journalist about russia
uh
and other people have said that putin is
relatively cool proof
he's pretty he's done a pretty good job
of insulating himself he monitors
everybody around him
and
he's
you know relatively
somewhat
you know as invulnerable as you can be
even though there's always a chance
there's a shot
but now they're saying there's a coup
and the that the oligarchs are unhappy
because they're losing money and the new
guy is gonna be the guy who's the head
of the fsb right now
uh and i forget his name
but they're saying there's a new uh guy
that the oligarchs in russia are tapping
to replace uh vladimir putin
victor yanukovich nope
that's not it ben okay let me try again
we're gonna miss
from producer extraordinaire man and
avery swinging a miss it wasn't the
surge guy either right it's not shogu
sergey shogu shout out to shogu
shogu's an urban an early uh supporter
of the show ironic
that we're in the position we are now
um of course this has been uh every
article
it's the head of the russian fsb now we
could just google that
we could google
head
of the russian
fsb
there it is alexander bortnikov
he is a russian intelligence officer who
has served as a director of the federal
security service since may 12 2008
they're now saying that the oligarchs
are mad they're going to throw putin out
and install
bortnikov now obviously this is probably
just
maybe some propaganda that we're
throwing out there to um
you know insert a little uh you know
distrust in the putin circle
whatever it is uh this is uh from what
publication this is from uh the tribune
in india
the tribune in india and but it's been
they've run it a bunch of places group
of russian elite plans to assassinate
putin by poison
claims ukrainian intelligence so
ukrainian intelligence claims that
there's a plot right now
to get rid of putin
and then replace him with the head of
the fsb who will restore economic ties
with the west that is you know i don't
know if that's true or not
um but that's ukrainian intelligence
saying that bring this up uh zielinski
they're saying his green shirt
has become a symbol of defiance
zielinski's green shirt this is the new
york times by the way this isn't
this isn't uh like a blog written by a
student at columbia university
there it's the man in the olive tree how
president
valor damir
zelinski of ukraine transformed the
meaning
of a piece of cotton
oh god
in the beginning it was just a t-shirt
basic olive green the kind worn under
military fatigues were hauled out from
the bottom of a wardrobe for workouts
and weekends
sometimes it was more brown than green
sometimes there was a cross over the
heart with a coat of arms in the center
but over the last four weeks as the
ukrainian president velodemir zielinski
has shed his former navy suits white
shirts and ties the uniform of the
politician for the t-shirt wearing it in
his daily videos to his country in his
speeches to the european parliament to
the british parliament to the american
congress in his interviews over the
weekend with cnn blah blah blah
uh a zoom call with asha kutcher and
mila kunis i mean what is happening uh
it he did a zoom
a widely tweeted zoom call with ashton
kutcher and and mila kunis uh it is
something more a symbol of the strength
of patriotism of the ukrainian people a
host of values here's the deal i've been
up front from the beginning the war is a
tragedy putin's a monster invading a
sovereign nation is absolutely wrong but
putin has a nuclear arsenal and sadly
has done this he chose to do this he
didn't chose to you know he didn't
choose to become a chef or a stand-up
comedian or whatever he's a dictator and
he's doing horrible things he's
killing women and children this is a
horrible thing whether it's done in
ukraine or iraq or where it's done it's
bad but it's been done and we're living
in that world and my problem with the
zielinski thing is what is the end game
here i mean we're talking about the guys
t-shirt and they're shelling cities
should we not be trying to pressure the
guy into making a deal
and saying hey man we get it you know
the ukrainian people are tough
but we need to figure out a way to end
this war
and not
you know
make it into some type of
this isn't a party
i'm afraid yeah no we're it is scary
scary can we go back to hating white
people right
i thought this country hated like white
people why is the media so in love with
the white ukrainians well they and when
some of them are not some of them are
legitimately nazis the a's off battalion
they're siege highland they're
legitimate
it's not even like
maybe they're nazis
it's like they're certainly
nazis
and
they're singing at the academy awards
liaison battalion
which is
odd
but
necessary
um the t-shirt is a reminder of mr
zielinski's origins as a regular guy a
connection between him and the citizen
soldiers fighting on the streets i get
it
listen
putin's invasion is not justified
because they have some nazi battalions
over there but the nazi battalions
aren't great an article is about the
ukraine before the warning and none of
this justifies the invasion but they
were like it's one of the most corrupt
countries they've got a huge nazi
problem uh lgbt attacks are becoming
more coordinated these are all things
that were said about the ukraine i mean
ukraine is probably not
a progressive paradise
um
you know
but but it still doesn't mean that putin
is is you know seriously denazifying the
country um
but i just think we need to push for
some type of so we're getting too into
zielinski as a guy
we're and he's getting too into this
it it almost feels like he's like what
happens when they say it's like his
covet where it's like hey man
you're gonna have to give putin some
territory
this is the way it's gonna work you're
not gonna get out of this without giving
putin territory he's kind of becoming a
little fouchy-like where he's just he's
doing podca the country's getting killed
and he's on my favorite murder
i mean this is a problem
right i mean there's there's
gotta be
some
idea of concessions being made by the
ukraine that they're not gonna be happy
about because otherwise we're gonna see
more death and more chaos and more
carnage and i just fee and i respect i
understand zelinski's in a spot and he
didn't leave his people he didn't they
didn't
he didn't take the airlift out of the
country that's all respectable he's to
be respected for that
but what we have to be careful about is
we we just can't have a guy
who who's
kind of
and people are going to blame you
they're like well it's not his fault i
understand that but we can't drag this
out forever here
because you know people's lives are at
stake and there's already 10 million
people
that have left the ukraine and we also
can't just have a nuclear war which i
know disappoints
a lot of people in the ruling class that
think a nuclear war would be a great
idea the new york times by the way this
is a great article from the new york
times
uh they're now preparing you for like
nuclear war
the new york times is now going out and
saying hey
this nuclear war you're all freaked out
about is actually not gonna be that bad
i swear to god
they're going hey this this nuclear
exchange you've been dreading
is actually not
the nuclear exchange of the 50s
it's actually gonna be
much cooler than that
and uh
that's a little disturbing i don't love
that article that they wrote any article
that seems to minimize the damage a
nuclear war could do scares me it's a
little scary
here we go new york times the smaller
bombs that could turn ukraine into a
nuclear war zone
and
the whole thing here
they had like a sub
uh title here
which was was basically
and maybe they changed this but the the
thing that i tweeted uh was essentially
they were saying like
experts say a new generation of less
destructive nuclear arms may make the
prospect of a nuclear strike less
unthinkable
than it once was
so they're like hey
what's the big deal
you don't want nuclear war
is that what you're saying
i mean i i think the point is like hey
we can't we give you there could be a
few nukes right that go off it's not a
big deal
it's not a big deal
there could be a few nukes
we don't want we don't want it to get
too
crazy concern about these smaller arms
has soared as vladimir putin in the
ukraine war
has warned of his nuclear might
has put his atomic forces on alert and
has had his military carry out risky
attacks on nuclear power plants the fear
is that if mr putin feels cornered in a
conflict he may choose to detonate one
of the lesser nuclear arms breaking the
taboo sat 76 years ago after hiroshima
and uh
nagasaki somebody goes to chances are
low but rising um
and they are
they are rising steadily because we
i don't think fully understand the
sanctions have crippled their economy
and he's this guy's desperate
and again we keep running articles
saying he's losing
every fight i mean he's just not
you know the whole media angle here is
like he's he's lo it's over for you
every late night shows us talking openly
about assassinating him and yeah people
are making jokes about killing him
no it's a great idea i'm afraid james
corn said oh we can we can just kill him
let's kill vladimir putin he's lost the
war
[ __ ] nuka's [ __ ] it's like
it's a bit it's a bit much
i don't know what to think about all of
this you know i mean uh you know
i'm i'm a fan of a non-nuclear uh uh
arrangement here same a non-nuclear
yeah i mean doesn't the new york times
writer of this article doesn't he know
he dies too like like all the people
pushing this isn't it just suicide like
we all die some of them do some of them
have bunkers under the ground
some of them in dc and yeah some some
people
are
have been preparing for this believe
it's an inevitability
believe it you know
they also don't you know a bunch of
people die they go ah you know
you get back on track
we get back on track after that i read
that nuclear war would wipe out like 700
million people and anything hey
by the way inflation not a big problem
anymore
[Laughter]
nothing brings the inflation numbers
down like a nuclear war
you get rid of 700 million people that's
a good idea
all of a sudden things start to seem
because a few you know maybe 100 to some
million of them are from our country
things start to seem a lot more
reasonable yeah when you start shedding
people we gotta shed people here there's
no other way around it we gotta shed
people so whether it's a nuclear war or
not
people gotta go
do you use a vpn
no why i don't know
expressvpn protects your privacy and
security online right but here's
something you may not know you can also
use expressvpn to unlock movies and
shows that are only available in other
countries and if you're like me you run
out of stuff to watch
netflix
you know but you get it in other
countries
so this whole week i've been using
expressvpn to binge the office on the uk
netflix it's so simple to do i just fire
up the expressvpn app change my location
to the uk refresh netflix and that's it
see expressvpn lets you control where
you want
sites to think you are located you can
choose from almost 100 different
countries so just think about all the
netflix libraries you can go through
love korean dramas
go to south korea netflix but it's not
just netflix expressvpn works with any
streaming service hulu bbc player
youtube you name it there are hundreds
of vpns out there but the reason i love
expressvpn is to watch shows because
it's ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering or lag you can stream in hd no
problem expressvpn also works on all
your devices phones media consoles smart
tvs and more you can watch what you want
on the go or the big screen so if you
want to get access to hundreds of new
shows
like the kardashians
use my link now expressvpn.com tim
dillon and you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free
that's
expressvpn.com tim dillon expressvpn.com
tim dillon to learn more i use
expressvpn and love it it's my favorite
thing
ever
sometimes you're sad have you ever been
sad yeah have you ever been mad yeah
have you ever felt bad yeah
well
better help
okay
counseling
is done better online as a fact
in the person now
is disgusting
but if you're online you can uh me i
can't believe i forgot he was here
she's here
but if you're uh
express vp
[Laughter]
better help relationships take work a
lot of us will drop anything to go help
someone we care about we'll go out of
our way
to treat other people well but how often
do we give ourselves the same treatment
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you to take care of your
most important relationship the one you
have yourself
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for your haircut or even trying therapy
you are your greatest asset so invest
the time and effort into yourself like
you do for other people
i love better everyone i know uses it we
all use it we go on there you can
communicate with the counselor and under
48 hours you could change a counselor if
you don't like the counselor that you
have it's essential it's important it's
beautiful
i love it better help online therapy
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours give it a try and see why over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy this podcast is sponsored
by better help the tim dillon show
listeners get percent off their first
month at betterhelp.com timd that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com tim d this podcast is sponsored
by better help online therapy
how bad is the economy right now i mean
what is the price of gas
i saw california it was uh six on
average
it's 696 near where i live average u.s
let's see four 696
even in your neighborhood in like a
little closer to downtown but yeah it's
really sad yeah
man yeah but it's about four
four six four nine national average is
4.2
do you have the cold bear bit
let's get the colbert bit up about i
wonder if we can play can we play it
what's he doing why can't we play it uh
because it's copyright of uh what is
that cbs or yeah they they understand we
got an arrangement with them
i do i got an arrangement with viacom um
i can
i'm i'm good
no colbert where he tells everybody to
go buy a tesla oh that's right
i'll tell you what i will never complain
about a destination wedding again
russia has been hit with a series of
crippling sanctions and it looks like
there's more to come because the us
and its european allies are now
discussing banning imports of russian
oil take that putin we're not going to
buy our gas from a war criminal we're
going to buy it from the good guys saudi
arabia
but
it's going to cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two no i'm willing to
it's
pay
right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
right now people all over the world are
trying to find uh inventive ways to help
ordinary
yes so i mean you know i i you know i
get it the saudi joke's pretty funny but
you know telling people you can spend
another dollar or two on a gallon of gas
and you know you know that's not helping
right i don't think that really warms
the hearts of
people in this country who are destitute
makes you furious watching yeah it makes
you angry uh watching it because people
are suffering already
and i don't think that there's a real
good
you know a clean conscience i mean
clean conscience
what are we doing in like yemen yeah
like
pull up yemen by the way see what's
going on over in yemen just a little bit
image just hit google image yemen
alrighty
yeah
go to the third photo over there
yeah what's that
what happened there
that looks like a scene out of the bible
what's going on over there that seems to
be a problem too
but nobody's talking about a dollar to
uh gas for yemen jesus saudi arabia has
been uh bombing yemen
with american money
and american equipment for years they've
been carrying out what essentially
amounts to a genocide in yemen
and
this is why people hate late night
comedy they hate performative activism
they hate all this stuff because they
know they they genuinely
know that it's fake
and that it's very selective
and that it only
you know it's a zeitgeist thing it's the
in thing to do
and they're going to have a thing on the
academy awards and i'm not saying that
the ukraine is not something that's
you should you should feel horrible
about and and notice but saying well you
could have a clean conscience you should
never with the things this government's
done you should never go to bed with a
clean conscience
if you're paying a tif you've read a
book
no clean conscience at all
um
amy schumer tried to get zalinski on the
show we talked about this on the patreon
we're not going to go over it again uh
but the oscars has said no to that
they've said no which is sad
because i wanted to see that same i
wanted to see zielinski on the academy
awards doing a comedy bit with amy
schumer while his country's being uh
attacked
i think that'd be a good use of his time
to uh be on the academy awards
making
doing a bit
about the the shelling of the country
what if zielinski really came on and
they just did some
like
bit
that just didn't land
about
now
the nazis in the ukraine
now they're and they're taping people
that are looting and stuff to things and
people are going look at them they're
doing the wrong thing i mean by the way
i mean all the things america's done
with you know
i mean taping people to a poll is not
even the least of it
but they are taping uh people you know
it's martial law over there it's not
great
so if they think somebody is alluding or
something
they're taping them to a poll
and this has made people very
uncomfortable
that are
watching this
trying to figure out you know
what our role should be
vigilante punishment spreads into
ukraine and a lot of people
that are doling out these punishments
are this azov battalion of nazis
um
but they're not the bad not they're not
like the nazis like that are like the
charlottesville like they're these are
like
there's hot different kinds of not like
there's like different kinds of nazis
and people don't realize this and like
these nazis are in
when a nazi is hot in this business
they're hot
let's get real
when a nazi has heat
in the entertainment business they got
heat
it's a business about heat not about
talent per se but it's about heat and
when you're hot you're hot
and right now the azov battalion is
hot
we like them they're in
we want to know more
we like it they're patriotic they're
standing up to putin
um so
they're not
the nazis that are out there's nazis
that are out
that we we say they're not marketable
and let's get them off social
let's get him off social media let's put
him in the back of the room
not a fan of those nazis but then there
are nazis uh
they're a little more cinematic
it's more exciting they're more exciting
the industry kids they're industry kids
they're we hand-picked them they're
selected you've been selected
as of battalion
they're the nazis of the moment
they're the nazis of the moment
and here's the deal
and this is i'm going to this is going
to come out wrong
i'm trying to figure out how to say it
and remain
with the ability to communicate with
large numbers of people but here's what
i'll say
in every now and then
you need
a cool
group of nazis
every now and then
not a lot
you don't want to overdo it
but every now and then
you need to overlook some [ __ ]
and just elevate
a cool
group of nazis
because
hey
it's punk rock
it's punk rock
and we forget about that
we forgot we've gotten soft
but
now do you they just the the azov nazi
guy literally just
was broadcast on cnn and they had them
on yeah yeah they had him on
they had him on
let's see here they had him on
they had him on to make his case
malcolm nance on twitter says there's no
nazis left in the asap italian that
though they've been rid of all nazis
well that's disappointing isn't it yeah
and
here's what i say about that
i don't believe that
but maybe after this happens the azo
battalion's hearts will be warmed
by amy schumer yeah what if amy schumer
convinces the azov battalion
to stop
being nazis
and start
queering the space
by accepting
lgbtq
ia2
people into their brigade
perhaps
so now we have the a's of the head of
the a's off battalion here yeah his name
is dennis uh
dennis i'm trying to pronounce don't
even try
don't even try with the names
here's the clip here now cnn has spoken
with a commander a ukrainian military
commander who's been defending the city
from the siege take a listen to what he
sent us a day ago
people are cooking food in the streets
risking their lives is under their
container let me be honest
i get a nazi vibe
if it was just based on vibes
if it was just based on vibes
i get a nazi vibe
not saying what what the defending of
the city is bad
not saying you don't have to make
alliances with people that are nutty
but i get a little bit of a nazi vibe
from this gentleman
that could be wrong
let's see what he has to say
as the temperature is minus five degrees
celsius in the street killing the
civilian as the amount of weak sims
grows every day now it is uh more than
three thousand but nobody knows the
exact amount because people are buried
together in the same dump with no names
many bodies are just outside the streets
without being buried some of people are
under the ruined buildings buried alive
ukrainian army is trying to help
civilians with food and water but it's
not enough
there is no safety places for people in
mariupol the missiles of the enemy are
attacking the houses and people are
dying in their beds
it's a horrible situation
um
that needs to end
truly i mean there you know this can't
this is it this has to end we have to
figure a way out of this
uh
and you know
you know i i don't want to you know we
can't split hairs here about you know
yeah we got there's some nazis there
that are
they're doing the work
they put their head down
they're doing the work
the nazis were very bad but they were
they weren't inefficient
so if you could get the nazis to do
things you want them to do
like what about a nazi run steakhouse be
great
right
so if we could focus nazis on
other things
we're doing the right thing here yeah
i love bespoke post in the box of
awesome
because i hate knowing what i'm getting
but i like surprises do you ever ever
use a box of awesome no
but i will now
box of awesome you fill out a quiz
and you say what you like
and then they give that to you every
month
seventy dollars worth of stuff it costs
you 45 a month you could send it to
somebody who's going away to college
somebody you don't see as much anymore
it's pretty damn awesome okay it's
pretty awesome to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome dot com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month this really is cool
stuff
you could say oh i'm an outdoorsy person
they give you a
a knife and a
deer feed it's good or if you say i like
drinking a lot they give you a little
martini shaker a couple of bottles of
hooch
each box is valued at around 70 you only
pay a fraction of the price plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small business 90 of everything that
comes in your box of awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand it's free to
sign up you can skip a month or cancel
any time get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of awesome
dot com and enter the code tim dillon at
checkout that's box of awesome dot com
code tim dillard for 20 off your first
box they support this show if you like
this show support box of awesome
you've got back-to-back meetings errands
to run chores to take care of what's the
secret to clearing your to-do list a
little help from doordash you can get
dinner household essentials and
everything on your grocery list
delivered ever pull into the driveway
after a trip to the grocery store only
to realize you forgot the one key
ingredient for dinner now you have
options get the groceries you need or a
backup meal from your favorite local
restaurant delivered with what doordash
what do you want to eat tonight maybe
you want a home-cooked favorite but you
don't feel like going to the store or
maybe you want something exciting and
new but it would be great to stay in
tonight doordarsh connects you with
everything you want whenever and however
you want it it's time to get back out
there but not if you're quite ready
maybe you're not quite ready for a
full-blown adventure there's still ways
to explore the world to the comfort of
your own home with doordash you don't
need to travel far to experience
something new get what you want to eat
right now and right to your door with
doordash along with the restaurants you
love you can now get groceries essential
items all delivered with doordash it's
amazing with over 300 000 partners you
can support your neighborhood go to's or
choose from your favorite national
chains like popeyes chipotle or the
cheesecake factory ordering is easy and
your items will be left safely outside
your door when you choose contactless
delivery drop off for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordarsh
app and enter code tim dillon that's 25
off up to 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code tim dillon don't
forget that's code tim dillon for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
to change terms apply
what about this katenji brown jackson uh
the woman who's uh the supreme court
people are getting mad at her because
she's uh
i don't know there's some uh he she
sends some people with child porn to uh
i don't know people not a lot of
i don't know people want her to sentence
it's very late but people wanted to
sentence uh the the people at the child
porn for uh
longer periods of time but apparently
so josh hawley went at her
and i don't know if she had a response
to that
um
so she's going to push back here
forcefully she's that smart woman and
so she's supreme court things
what were you gonna say she just like
gave him a slap on the wrist like it
wasn't life i think she did like three
months a few times
yeah it was you know
i don't know the circumstances of every
case
but i think she was like listen
you know
we all do it you know i think maybe it
was
that's what she said
i think it was kind of uh
hey
you
know
you didn't see that stop sign
type of thing
it was a fix-it ticket
you know she's saying they're they're
saying that she sentenced the defendants
to an average of 47 last time than what
other what the prosecutors asked for but
let's watch her push back she firmly
pushed back on that
here we go here we go came up yesterday
in the
opening
phase of this
nomination hearing
and it's the issue involving child
pornography
i want to turn to that issue because it
was raised by the times primarily i mean
is this country not beyond over
i mean what an embat what an
embarrassing country to live in at this
point
it's been the most apocalyptic lineup of
topics i mean
i mean can you even imagine this
okay we got the supreme court nominee
and hey
we want to cover uh child porn and
you're letting these guys off
you're letting these guys off their
kitty porn cases
explain
yourself i mean this is the
and i mean i hope she's not doing that
but people are saying she is let's see
what she says please
senator from missouri
and it was he was questioning your
sentencing record in child pornography
cases
that do not involve the production of
pornographic material i thought about
his charges as i watched you and your
family
listening carefully yesterday
and what impact it might have had on you
personally as a mother
and a judge who has had
to deal with these cases
i was thinking
that nothing could be further from the
truth
get this woman's response up benjamin
please
they've leveled a serious accusation
this yeah they cut it off this is the
rest of it here
[Music]
come on yeah the rest is in text i tell
them about the adults who are former
child sex abuse victims tell me that
they will never have a normal adult
relationship because of this abuse i
tell them about the ones you say i went
to prostitution i fell in the drugs i
was trying to suppress to hurt there was
done to me as an infant
almost every one of these sentences when
i look in the eyes of the defendant
who's weeping because of giving him a
significant sentence what i say to him
is do you know that there is someone who
has written to me and told me that she's
developed agoraphobia she cannot leave
her house because she thinks that
everyone she meets um will
have seen her we'll have seen her
pictures on the internet they're out
there forever
at the most vulnerable time of her life
so she's paralyzed she added i tell that
story to every child porn defense did
she just work child porn
is that was that
was that it oh god was that all she
worked
was child pornography
wasn't it
wasn't there anything else
oh
what is there any are there no other
cases in front of this woman
and i don't know i i i they're saying
she's been lenient on this but i mean i
i don't know i hope not
yeah i hope not either that'd be
horrible
but i mean here's the deal
i don't know if these cases are like a
19 year old has sex with a 17 i don't
know what's going but there was one case
i think when the guy was 18 and the
person was eight that's not funny okay
no i mean that's supposedly that was one
of the cases i don't know
i don't know i mean it's like
you know we're progressing as a country
and
i mean
and then they go into the critical race
theory yeah how about we figure out the
child porn first how do we just bounce
from that
so now let's go let's talk about the
don't say a gay
in florida because this is uh i've
solved this issue and again
i solved it on youtube
literally last week
where i said you do a take a tit leave a
tit where you give the kids prosthetics
fake dicks fake tits they don't make
irreversible physical changes to their
bodies you give them prosthetic dicks
and tits
and [ __ ]
and you hand them out if they want them
it's a good idea
it's a great idea you go to the guidance
counselor you get a puss
for the day
[Laughter]
you know i'm dead serious
and that way nobody can say they're
doing irreversible and if they grow out
of it and then when they get older if
they go yeah i want a real puss to get a
real puss if they grow out of it they
give the dick back and everybody and
they graduate
yeah
is am i nuts or is that not a humane
compromise
yeah
the parents on the way to the school
they could don't forget your dick
they grabbed the dick
i know this sounds like i'm making light
of everything
but that's kind of what i have to do
i i mean i know that comedy now is about
my truth
this is my trip my personal truth
it's not about you the audience of slobs
got bust in here
it's about my own personal truth i'm
plumbing the depths of myself i'm so
goddamn significant
i need to continually plumb the depths
of myself cause there's so much fair
there's some i have layers
and they're gonna be peeled off
peel the layers off one by one
make myself vulnerable in front of a
room full of people
disney workers walked out
over the company's response to the don't
say gay bill well what is the company's
response to the don't say gay bill
the recent statements by the walt disney
company leadership recording the florida
legislature's recent don't say gay bill
have utterly failed to match the
magnitude of the threat
posed by the legislation
so disney's kind of just going hey let's
just
disney's being disney they're not taking
a hard stance on this but disney's
pretty pro-gay right they've been pretty
broke like ben shapiro's doing these
things where he's like the disney world
disney world has been taken over by
lgbtq people
gay people have taken over disney
disney's been completely gay forever
it's been gay
every single movie is about uh guys
sucking each other off that's what it's
about
um
so now they're saying they can't uh
employees are calling for
dissent uh the disney to stop uh making
donations to certain florida politicians
including ron desantis
and commit to a plan to protect
lgbtqia staff
from such legislation so what do you
mean protect the staff what do i mean by
the put them in the magic kingdom
put them in a castle
i don't understand how you're going to
protect the gay staff this bill's about
two-year-olds it's about second graders
not being instructed to gender ideology
how many second graders are working for
disney
i don't understand we're going to
protect the staff
it's about kids
about it's like third grade and under
organizers of the walkout claimed
that some employees of disneyland in
california who
who did not feel safe to walk on tuesday
were told they
they couldn't wear pride trans mickey
pants
which they said disney sells to show
their support
i want a trans mickey pin
so they're basically saying
you can't wear trans mickey pins
at disney world which i don't agree with
let them wear the trans pen of mickey
what does that look like the trans
mickey pin can you get a trans mickey
pin up for christ mickey pin he's always
behind the eight ball oh okay it's the
trans uh
flag with the mickey
i believe that's a transplant let him
wear it
nobody even knows what it means
people don't know what that is
no
somebody from alabama is gonna be like
there's purdy curlers well actually i'm
glad it's a trans-mickey pen
what
it's a trans-mickey pin gender's not
real
just just put them on space mountain
why does everything have to be a big
fight
put them on space
mountain and have them eat the [ __ ] food
stand in the lines spend their money and
leave
so they did this walkout at disney world
by the way i think everyone should walk
out of disney world employees and
visitors and it should be burned to the
ground
i i don't understand as a gay person
who's been out for years and by the way
i am i do want to make an announcement
on the show i'm coming out as queer
because that means i'm gay but now i can
be in movies
i'm queer now it's so i'm not gay
because that's
a little nazi-ish but i'm queer meaning
that i'm gay
but more importantly i can be in movies
because i'm queer
now
which doesn't mean it just means that i
can be in the business again
i can be in the industry again i'm qui
i'm i'm other
i'm different
gender is a spectrum
and now why are they hanging a gay
mickey now what is going on here
so
they have a gay mickey
and
they've got tape around his arms
and he goes i'm walking out too
so
mickey is
walking out
i i'm i'm so confused about everything
now
this is them uh walking out right here
and uh looks like this is in burbank
okay
all right
i i can walk out no it's good it's good
i i
i'm i'm missing somebody who's queer
and now now has a career because i'm
queer
uh
yeah
queer is different than gay i it's it's
a whole thing
it's a whole thing i go to i get invited
now to events
it's a very big change
realizing that i was queer
because i i can't get anything in the
business made and put on television or
in a movie so i realized overnight that
i was i was queer
and that i had been suppressing that for
a very long time and i had only kind of
been gay which isn't doesn't really
mean anything uh and i realized that
gay is very it's an archaic concept
because it's based on gender which we
know isn't real
so the idea that i am attracted to
members of my same sex is it real
because there it there are no sexes
i'm queer
and now i'm going to be
the belle of the ball
and i'm excited about it
because i'm it's going to make me money
my sexuality should make me money
my identity should make me money
if if
if you're coming out of something now it
better be to make you money
don't even gay doesn't mean [ __ ] you
better come out as something that can
make you money
please
don't be stupid
um
so i'm proud to announce that i am
queer and i'm not i'm uh i refuse to do
business with disney
until they let people wear the trans
mickey pin in the haunted house
i mean
people can imagine ukraine reading this
there's just people sitting in a bunker
their entire lives have been destroyed
their buildings are just blowing up
and we're going no there's a there's a
pin
it's a it's a mickey pin and we were
told not to wear it
at tower of terror
as a part of the town hall disney
announced that mr chapack
had postponed a management retreat
planned for next week in orlando florida
he and senior executives would instead
use that time to go on a listening tour
at disney workplaces both domestically
and overseas good
because people are concerned and they
should have a listening tour they they
should listen to the employees that are
angry sit down and hear them out
somebody's wearing a shirt that is gay
and tired
well it ain't from exercise
because she's fat
that's why i've made that uh joke
there's a fat person
she's tired
people are angry
texas has gone nuts they're like
prosecuting transparent kids uh you know
trans kids that are getting medical
things whatever you think about that
texas is now we could prosecute their
parents that's insane
leave the family alone
yeah let them do whatever let them do it
i look at it like
you picked a you know you picked the
wrong major
texas court reinstates injunction
blocking probes of transgender kids so
greg abbott's going out of control
but the courts are stopping him
hmm
because
you know this is too unintrusive here
they're going hard with the
anti-abortion
you can't even have an abortion at
disney world now do you know this
no they
there was an abortion clinic in disney
world
and they're trying to ban it
you used to be able to have an abortion
and then go to epcot
now you can't
this is what i mean it's getting out of
hand
you know i love talking [ __ ] about
bitcoin but i'm also a [ __ ] comedian
it's kind of my job to talk [ __ ] not
give investing advice so when i get
serious to talk about an overlooked
alternative asset that's not nfts or
crypto you know it's special i'm talking
about high-end art and we're talking
about masterworks today's sponsor
masterworks makes it possible for you to
invest in blue chip art without being a
billionaire here's how it works this is
really cool actually masterworks offers
an investment in multi-million dollar
pieces of art works by icons like
picasso banksy so you can go out and
invest in a painting without paying 103
million dollars which is how much a
picasso last year sold for in new york
why did the super rich spend that much
money on a painting
is it because art prices have outpaced
the s p 500 by 164 percent from 1995 to
2020 nothing funny about those numbers
they didn't get rich by being stupid and
my friends over at masterworks are
giving my listeners priority access to
their latest offerings at masterworks
dot art slash tim that's masterworks dot
art slash tim
now do you own any picassos no not yet
no
but you understand why rich people buy
art totally and do you understand
how [ __ ]
people are out there right now yeah so
they're looking for a safe investment
and they should they should do this
well yeah
that's masterworks dot art slash tim see
important disclaimers at masterworks dot
io slash disclaimer let's talk about the
la mayor's race here before the end of
the show because you brought up a great
point we have a great new mayor
who uh or candidate
yeah caruso caruso and i i like this guy
because caruso built the americana in
glendale which is a disgusting outdoor
mall where animals go and they eat it to
cheesecake factory but he's going to
build one another version of it
exclusively for homeless people
and let them play in the fountains and
have fun
and [ __ ] wherever they want and i think
that's the move can you get up his ad
his advertisement oh yes yes they can't
get mad at us playing that no no no
rick caruso he's going to be the new
mayor
of los angeles because
he is uh
he's very good at building
malls so he's going to fix the problem
because the homeless crisis is really
because
they don't have a mall
i don't think he put on youtube but i
bet i could find out he's like
thank you ben you don't have to
telegraph what you're doing you can just
deliver
um
but i like if he goes he's like the
problem is that they don't homeless
people don't have a mall of their own
give them a mall
give them an outdoor mall where they can
conduct their business yeah give them a
call nobody goes around in anthropology
something's fun something fun
clear everyone out of h m let them go in
there
here's an ad he's running called faith
family and community
think nobody can clean up l.a yes meet
rick caruso uh-oh lifelong angelino
husband father grandson of immigrants
raised to put faith family and community
first a lifelong builder and job creator
that's right we created the southland's
most beloved community centers and he
always shares that success
what are you talking about
the americana is a beloved community
center
it's a corporate hellscape
it's a beloved community center people
in glendale don't know where to go yeah
i mean it's a big outdoor mall just a
community center
he hands out turkeys on thanksgiving
like frank lucas rick caruso's a
lifelong angelino
he's made billions of dollars building
outdoor malls and now he's ready to
build one for the homeless
keep going ben
giving millions to provide health care
and a good education to kids in la's
poorest neighborhoods and giving
tirelessly of himself first appointed by
tom bradley he served la under three
different mayors fought corruption and
waste and cut crime 30 percent
i'm running for mayor because the city
we love is in a state of emergency
rampant homelessness people living in
fear for their safety and politicians at
city hall just in it for themselves my
only special interest is los angeles the
city we love
it's why i'll work for a dollar a year
and i won't take a dime from special
interest i'm already together
i'll work for a dollar a year i'm
already loaded
and i'm a little sick of this city
getting less comfortable for me and my
friends
so i'm gonna work for a dollar a year
and we're gonna use direct energy
weapons on the homeless
you pay me a dollar a year
and i will have the lap lapd out there
with batons
every day it'll cost the taxpayers only
a dollar a year
for me to vaporize homeless people in
the middle of the night
so you can feel safe going to the
americana in glendale and getting a
[ __ ]
herb crusted salmon at the cheesecake
factory for 48 dollars
i feel like the people in this don't
even know they're in a rick caruso ad he
just took photos of people
the city we love
finish this
we can clean up la read my action plan
at carusocan.com
rick caruso can clean up la
now get an interview of him up before we
get out of here because maybe i'm making
fun of this guy but
yeah i got one right here maybe maybe
this guy's got a plan because you've
lived here forever tell people about it
later real quick
uh it's a great place a lot of homeless
people well what's what are the problems
the homeless
and he's gonna handle it
look at this man
he's gonna fix it
rick caruso will work for a dollar
this [ __ ]
it's these dumb
slogans
i'll work for a dollar a year why the
dollar
just say you have to make something
like
i got to be able to go home and look at
my wife
so i need at least a dollar a year
let's see what maybe i'm wrong let's see
rick
about sort of what separates you because
ultimately this is a job interview right
and people got to pick who is the best
person for this job
you have a different biography than most
of the other people that are running
where are you
the most qualified person to lead la
when a lot of the people you're running
against have a lot more experience in
government they haven't built a
cheesecake factory let me first talk
about them generally
which is an important question that
you've asked
they've had a lot of opportunity they've
had decades of public service to get
something done and they haven't they
failed and i just find it interesting
that you've got a group of people that
are tasked
with making the city safe and livable
and they've had a decade to get it done
they failed but they wanted raise and a
job promotion that wouldn't happen
anywhere else right and so if you think
they've done a good job i'm not your
candidate if you want more of the same
i'm not your candidate
let me tell you about rick caruso i've
worked hard i'm from humble beginnings
i love life i love giving back and i've
got a track record
of moving into a situation where there's
a serious problem or a crisis and fixing
it i came into lapd it was last summer
at the cheesecake factory at the
americana there was a crisis
because
one of the chefs was drunk every day and
he was burning the chicken fish
and if you know anything about the
cheesecake fact we got great chicken
fingers in there so what i did was i
sent him to a rehabilitation program and
brought in another chef who was actually
my deadbeat cousin my deadbeat cousin
came in there and he actually did a
great job but that's the kind of
experience i have
under a federal consent decree run by a
federal judge crime was spiking i
reformed lapd hired bill bratton we
dropped crime by 30 percent that was a
crisis situation
asked to step up at usc
we turned usc around with a lot of help
from leadership but that's a very
different enterprise today this works
the only people committing crime in this
city will be the cops
[Laughter]
if my plan is
if my plan is enacted the only dangerous
people in this city will be the police
i want to restore la back to the rampart
pd days
as we know the lapd is a great
institution and i'm proud
proud to i reform them that involved
telling them hey hey
do it quietly
i reform the lapd with my do it quietly
program
do it quietly
it's the uh my do it quietly
it's very successful
where we
we
encourage cops to behave exactly as they
were but quietly you bust that guy's
head in quietly
i'll make a big deal about everything
see the rest of this i'm you know what
this guy's i i'm starting to believe in
him
yeah he's good four years ago when i
took over his chair
and i have this passion about los
angeles and we're in a crisis that's
what it is let's say what it is
and i've got a track record
of being able to manage through a crisis
lead
i'll hold myself accountable i'll make
tough decisions
and i'm not looking for another job i
want to be mayor i want to get a job
done and go home i'm not looking at
making decisions through a political
lens to get reelected like all of my
other candidates who are running are
doing uh and when you say usc you were
chairman of the board of trustees at usc
uh fight on so uh
let's talk about because we know the two
biggest issues right now you lead with
them in your campaign why don't we ever
see the faces
let's start with this milo yiannopoulos
[Laughter]
why don't we why don't we ever see the
face of the interviewer this is
incredibly disgusting have you ever seen
an interview like this
you don't even see the face of the
interviewer
i mean what is happening
i guess fox 11 only brought one camera
yeah
and why is he being interviewed in a
restaurant i don't know it's like
what's going on
[Laughter]
all right keep going all right all right
i'm some of your critics point to the
fact that you supported george gascon
for district attorney do you regret that
and do you now support his recall
so i knew george when i was the
president of the police commission and
he was a deputy chief and he wanted to
be chief i didn't make him chief he
wasn't ready for it at the time and i
hired bill bratton
now he left and became the chief at mesa
arizona that went up to san francisco i
knew a very different george now what
happened to george on his journey from
mesa to san francisco that changed the
way he thought about fighting crime is
very different than where he was so
early in his campaign i did support him
he was a friend i knew him from from our
time to get lapd once his campaign
started rolling out and i was hearing
about what his plans were i quickly
pivoted
and i gave to jackie lacy and i gave her
a significant amount of money to support
her so
i regret what george has done and i
think george either needs to stand up
and say the policies that i've put into
place are harming our communities and
i'm going to change them
or he should step down and if he doesn't
step down he should be recalled because
he is harming our communities and i
stand with charlie beck
and i stand with bill bratton that said
the same thing this was a different
george than we all knew when we worked
at lapd together i don't know what's
happened but clearly he's got to change
or he's got to go the other big issue is
homelessness yep
number one thing you're going to do
that's going to be different than the
people that have been in there so far
day one declare a state of emergency
move the authority into the mayor's
office i'll be accountable to fix it i'm
going to build the smartest team in the
country to go fix the problem
we're going to go build
30 000 temporary beds we've got excess
land throughout the city that's declared
surplus land
we're going to give people an option to
move into a clean safe place in a very
humane way give them the right services
that they need mental health physical
health but you don't get a choice to
stay on the street anymore the minute we
have a bed for you
you move into the bed or otherwise
there's a consequence to being on the
street
you have to draw a bright line
that we've got communities you have
what you have to do
is you have to do the best finishes
you have to really do indoor outdoor
living because a lot of them are outdoor
anyway you have to do indoor outdoor
living you need large windows lots of
natural light
you need buildings with gyms you know we
need to move them into into luxury yeah
yeah so we're going to build all these
luxury units and if the homeless people
can't afford them we just sell them to
foreign billionaires
but the most important thing
we're gonna give the homeless people the
option to get a job that pays a lot of
money and move into these units for 18
000 a month and if they can't afford
that we're gonna just get put these
units on the market at market value and
uh we'll leave the homeless exactly
where they are
that are severely impacted by
encampments you can't tolerate it
anymore when you say there's a
consequence what does that mean you're
arrested you probably are arrested if if
we give you a bed and we give you the
services and we clean you and we feed
you and support you and i think there
should be retraining programs to get
people back on their feet that can get
back on their feet
why then should we allow people to live
on the street good point and where do
you draw that line
you can't and that's what's happened
with this problem everybody has been
so politically correct
in their mind whatever that means to
deal with it
the problem has just gotten larger let's
talk about your place in this race um
you live a very comfortable lifestyle
after working really hard and being very
successful in business that is the
american dream right right but the
average american doesn't live your
lifestyle the average los angelino
doesn't live your lifestyle how do you
relate to somebody who's struggling to
pay the bills
well let me tell you again i grew up
with immigrant parents from italy that
lived in boyle heights and my
grandfather was a gardener and i
remember riding in his truck and i
remember a family
that lived from paycheck to paycheck
there was always a meal on the table
always my father was an italian fascist
he was a supporter of mussolini
how do you relate to the regular people
my father was a fascist who supported
mussolini they live paycheck to paycheck
and he used to read books on hitler
so i know exactly what people in this
country are going through right now
i can relate to all of them
thank you so much
let's hear the rest of his answer
to paycheck great pride being an
american and great belief in this city
and that's the spirit i do this with but
i have also spent the last 30 years
working in east l.a and working in watts
supporting the underserved education and
health care coverage the track record
and the understanding and the families
that i know down there that my children
have worked with that we come personal
friends with i understand it i've got
people who leave space for me that are
small businesses that struggled during
the pandemic we waived all the rent we
wrote everything on the right we
supported them financially because i
started as a small business i started
with victims no business
and i built it so i do understand it so
this notion
that i don't connect i'm probably more
connected
because of our work in the inner city
than most people and and i want to
expand
helping
the great people of the city especially
those that really need help
by being mayor that would be a great
gift to me i'd be honored to do that
all right that's rick i mean i don't
know i maybe he'll be good
he's the only person with evidence of
something that he did that i could like
go to how about this uh one there trying
to get elected all my uh uh comic
friends on the east side they're trying
to get to eunice elected let's get you
niece up before we get out of here let's
see
eunice um
she's running sato
no no
hold on i might be pronouncing your name
wrong
i'm gonna
i'll get it right now
uh it's for
e-u-n-i-s-s-e-s eunices
and she is uh running for i don't know
city council hernandez yeah i believe so
yes
now let's get um
let's get an interview with her okay
now i don't think she's running for the
same thing
what
now
let's see her
advertisement because we're in l.a now
and we want to we want to protect the
people what we going to say what's her
mall
she's not built a mall
she's not built them all she's got a
couple of tables set up on the street
where they're selling fruit
but that's nice i like fruit keep going
okay this is uh los angeles for the
people who i believe it's an ad
what makes la home
to me it's the people
[Music]
i grew up in highland park
when i was a kid we knew everybody in
the neighborhood
but slowly things started to
[Music]
their comedy change
people started wearing [ __ ] weird
hats
getting on stage and doing these [ __ ]
hipster dances
i didn't enjoy that
we wanted to kill those people but now
they tweet about me so they're cool
kidding kidding
then another
neighbors friends family locked up for
things like cannabis or mental health
crises when what they needed was care
in my moment of need i called 9-1-1 like
we're told to do the police came but
they wouldn't even get out of their car
so i went to school to become the law
enforcement officer who would have
helped me
we spend billions on overstuffed police
budgets instead of funding neighborhood
services that would help folks stay in
their homes
and that's how gentrification and
criminalization intersect
in the last 10 years
gentrification has devastated us
but it doesn't have to be this way i've
committed my life to undoing the harm
inflicted by this lack of investment in
our families youth and elders
and we're starting to win
we passed sentencing reforms to liberate
our neighbors and reunite families
we stopped the building of two new jails
and put that money into our community
during the height of the pandemic we got
millions of people to vote for measure j
which will fund the life-affirming
responses my loved ones and i deserved
in our time of need
my family had to fight to stay in our
neighborhood and against all odds we won
now
i'm running for city council to make
that easier for everybody in district 1
and across la the workers the young
people lgbtq plus folks black people
people of color immigrants we are the
community we deserve a city that cares
for our residents
that embraces our history
not erases our history
we deserve a city where the responses to
our most vulnerable moments are
life-affirming
we deserve a los angeles that's for the
people
[Music]
yeah i don't hate her i think she says a
lot of valuable stuff
i don't know if you can abolish the cops
i think she's on that train
um
i just don't think sending social
workers out to uh you know uh you know
violent crimes is probably the way to go
but i think she says a lot of valuable
stuff i think that
you know eudini you do need to find a
way
to not have gentrification
displace people
turn everything into a corporate mall
take away all the flavor and
individuality out of communities i think
she's right about that
i think she's probably got some wacky
batty ideas
that will end up getting a lot of people
killed
but
you know
see patrice culler's endorsers are from
blm this is the woman who bought four
houses with the money this is not what
we need oh that's her i believe so
yeah
unless i'm completely wrong about that
but i believe that is the case
uh
yes it's the abolition of the police is
really the wrong move yeah and i i i in
in
in that sense i don't think this but a
lot of what she's saying
i agree with
but i think you you need to retrain
police
you know
have them
be held to different standards
i just don't think getting rid of the
cops is a good move here
um
but i'm all for affordable housing
i think the prison system's a mess you
got to clean that up
i don't think anybody should be going
away for cannabis
i think but i mean again you start going
into the bail reform and you know people
get out of jail then they kill people
you know so i i do think there's a there
there's got to be a nuanced approach
here it can't be just like let's let
everybody out of the jails
and see what happens
it's not just going to be everybody
eating tacos on the street with the
guitars
which i know because if you watch her
if you watch the you know thing it's
just everybody playing guitars and
eating tacos there's a fair amount of
hell being unleashed in the city right
now too fair amount of you know people
uh being uh murdered
it's not just old tacos and fun and
sing-alongs
but you know i i don't i don't i don't
hate her
where where is she on the issues ben go
to the issues right here
she seemed earnest
currently nearly half of la city budget
is allocated to law enforcement
statistics and decades of tough on crime
policies prove that this does not result
in safer communities that's not true
i mean
literally
crime everywhere has gone down
except recently la needs urgent
widespread investment in mental health
services public health care afforded by
that's all true
that's all true
but you also need to retrain police with
money
you can't suck the funding out of
something
and then you know you don't
have the resources to retrain cops you
can't replace
cops i don't think that's you know you
can in certain instances
homelessness many uh on our streets
suffer with untreated mental health
needs problematic substance use and
physical health needs we must meet the
moment with proven and effective
services housing and strong renter
protections
okay but you know that's not exactly
not exactly specific
immigration i will fight for a fully
funded permanent universal justice fund
the right to vote in local elections for
angelino's regardless of citizenship
status
yeah i don't know that people are going
to be in for that either going if you're
not a citizen you can vote in the i mean
again that
that doesn't necessarily
get people excited
when you go whether you're a citizen or
not you can vote
um
[Music]
because if you
if you take that to its logical
conclusion you'll just have
tons of people that aren't citizens
coming to the country being entitled to
every benefit citizens and then then you
you you don't really have a country
you have a grab bag of things that
people want that they can just get and
that doesn't mean that a lot of these
people aren't won't become great
citizens but it's you know there's got
to be a process to make them citizens
and then when you are a citizen you're
entitled to things you should vote i
think if you're a non-citizen you should
be treated humanely
but i i just think there should be some
in every country in the world there is a
distinction between a citizen and a
non-citizen
every single country in the world it's
not america it's not white supremacy
it's not the patriarchy
it's just what it is but hey who gives a
[ __ ] i live in austin
[ __ ] it
gives a [ __ ] what happens to this dump
where does rick caruso live where's his
house at
i bet it's pasadena is he living like a
baller
he seems like a pasadena guy
he's just sick of oh look at this
look at this rick caruso pays 18.6
million for the newport beach mansion
next door that's what i'm talking about
nice
nice
rick
i think he has a house in brentwood too
that's right who wants to make the drive
oh here's his one in malibu tim he lists
it for 40 million
here's the deal malibu is just not the
hamptons it just isn't when you look at
these homes i mean i like malibu's
pretty but
yeah it's just not it
it's very pretty it's just there's no
taste look at the way the house it's
just no taste
it's a real problem
this is what he should have led with
should talk about real estate
be a gangster
he goes he goes i listed an oceanfront
property in malibu for 40 million
it went over market we closed at 42
million that's the experience i'm going
to bring to la
so you got a choice between him
this guy's got a real estate portfolio
that's half the city budget and then the
other girl who goes
and then the other girl who's like we
kill cops
if you see a cop we kill we kill them
two extremes
what are the changes you've seen in l.a
since you were a youth
uh it was about how it is now like crime
wise like when i was like a kid and then
yeah it got it got got better yeah and
then it got pretty good like when i was
in like high school and
up until basically the pandemic
and now it's kind of like
back to gunshots and tons of homeless
people and more homeless people than
i've ever seen in my life
so that's why i'm going to go with
caruso here
maybe we got to go with caruso and see
what happens we need an italian in there
yeah
we need a guy
he's going to put all the homeless in
like an abandoned
katsuya just close the door i'm building
another americana strictly for the
homeless
so that they can pretend to shop
play in the fountains take shits
wherever they want
we'll have fountains filled with
fentanyl
in the new outdoor mall strictly for the
homeless
designed by rick caruso
what do you think about caruso ben
uh cruz i mean he's a rich guy right so
he's insanely wealthy
and he's bored he's elderly
and he's bored let him [ __ ] around
yeah why not he's rich and he's bored
when rich people get bored they got to
get in there and try to pretend they're
going to fix it all
you're bored
what are you going to do you got 20
million in newport beach 40 million in a
mouth you're bored
go in there it's the natural progression
natural progression go in there and see
what you can do
he goes
we're gonna give the cops harpoons
[Laughter]
now what do you think rick how are you
going to handle it we're giving the cops
better weapons
direct energy
weapons there's there's pulses and
things you can do
and a lot of my friends at raytheon
we've been having lunch over at the
miramar hotel the rosewood mere mart's
lovely get the salmon and they've been
telling me there are direct energy
weapons we can use with pulses that will
make people instantly drop to the street
and start shaking
thank you rick
devin's got a very funny podcast called
hate watch where you uh
watch things you don't you dislike so
yeah it's kind of like this yeah yeah
it's not your show but this one in
particular yeah yeah
and uh and you were just on it it was it
was yeah we had a lot of people check
out that episode hate watch with uh dev
acosta yeah uh can we put id in the chat
or just talk about the kardashians for
five minutes sure
no no no no i can't i can't be on camera
right now okay can you from off camera
can you discuss
[Music]
tell us about the new kardashians you're
wearing your sunglasses
can you tell us about the new season
yeah i i can't say much but it'll be on
hulu
and i wouldn't be able to do about this
family so much because you really oh
now i respect them they got they've got
a trillion dollars now they have more
money than all of us they're more money
than the country i yeah they fascinate
me because i think they're the closest
thing this country has to a monarchy
that's true right rightfully so i mean
they're kind of the epitome of
capitalism but i think that they
actually uh they've kind of proven
themselves in a way i'm not even kidding
why not elect them i'm yeah
why not elect chris jenner
to be the mayor of l.a
no one's ever governor of california
like why not elect kris jenner to be the
man she'll make those homeless people
stars
truly
yeah no 100 percent she'll have those
homeless people [ __ ] each other on
camera she'll be releasing those tapes
homeless people just need a show
yeah homeless people really just need a
show
and the fact that they don't have one is
why they're not getting ahead in this
town and kris jenner will show them
how to play the game
she's efficient she's a beast she gets
it done
she absolutely gets it done this will
just be an elevated version i think of
the
e-show
well now what i liked about the uh
preview is they're threatening people
now that like we'll destroy them yes
like you know
it used to be kind of you know in the
background now they're saying we have
the resources and the time to just
destroy them all yeah like succession
like i wanna yeah yeah it's succession
for l.a it's succession for retards
it's what it is
it's succession but it's about lip gloss
and i think it's important
play the hulu can you play this ben the
new yeah i think we can if i hear music
though i'm gonna edit this out without
cameras it was a big change for us
[Music]
life without cameras was a big change
what did that last for two months
i think less
[Music]
it's succession so how does it feel to
be back
we've had so much time off we've kind of
gone into our own world
they own you you know this is what i
haven't been like
they're better than you
they own you
and you love it
and i've been in this game long enough
to know that you just have to be
yourself they're going to like you for
who you are not what you wear
i'm just kidding obviously
[Music]
tristan and i are complicated
trust takes time
travis and i want to have a baby
put the sample in this cup
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming who are you
texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
it's so easy to comment on people we
have no idea what they're actually going
through
it is really hard with kanye he told me
my career is over why are we always
making excuses for the people that
traumatize us i'm out this is so
ridiculous we have all the time and all
of the resources to burn them all to the
ground
never go against the family
never go against the family
[Music]
dude the last scene
should be just kris jenner
she like sits back
you know she like rolls back on like a
chair
and she just sits there and she turns
around and she just says hello vladimir
and putin just goes in and they start
making out
[Laughter]
jenner and vladimir putin just start
making out and they're like never go
against the family